hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others and I see that all
kinds of questions that have come in
let's see there's one here from Aaron
are all pixels squares or rectangles or
have other shapes
been used
well
another candidate shape will be hexagons
and
you know if you take for example let's
say you take a bunch of coins all
identical and you kind of push them
together they will arrange themselves
the closest packing of those coins will
be a hexagonal packing so you'll make a
bunch of little hexagon shapes there
it's kind of like the same shapes same
sort of structure of shapes that you
would find in a beehive this is the just
the way that packs circles closes
together and there are lots of places
where you'll see things that are packed
together like that that form a hexagonal
array you see that in you know tilings
in different places and and so on
well
for example the retina of our eye the
cells are arranged in a roughly
hexagonal pattern so in a sense the
pixels that we have in our eyes are
roughly hexagonal pixels now people have
tried uh doing using hexagonal pixels
both for cameras and for displays but
more so I think for cameras back in the
1950s when people were first trying to
do optical character recognition I think
some people tried using hexagonal uh
pixel arrays you know by the way insects
for example which have these compound
eyes with omitidia where they've got
lots of separate little uh you know
pieces of their eye that separately
sense light those are typically arranged
in a hexagonal grid so each each pixel
of an insect eye is effectively
hexagonal now just to say something
about how optical character recognition
works
uh so the the problem one's trying to
solve there is you've got a picture of a
letter A for example and you want to
recognize that it is the letter A as
opposed to a b or c or whatever else
and at this point the state of the art
in doing optical character recognition
is quite good so long as the image is
high enough resolution really has a hard
time if there aren't enough pixels per
letter but as soon as you have you know
uh 50 100 pixels across each letter or
something it's really no problem at this
point to be able to recognize that's an
a that's a b Etc et cetera et cetera a
cool thing we did recently actually for
wolfen Alpha for those who use that
um the the Wolfman Alpha app now does
math OCR so in a kind of uh kind of
convenient if you want to enter some
math formula and you have it printed in
a book yeah it could be a question in
some book or something you can just use
your phone to take a picture of that
question and uh we'll figure out what
that math formula was based on just the
image of the math formula we're talking
about OCR in general how does it work
so the first OCR that people did in the
19 well 50s and 1960s was just digits so
zero through nine and so for example
people wanted to do that when there were
checks that people wrote if anybody even
writes those anymore I don't know yeah
they must do they uh the the um uh where
well I know they do and and certain
kinds of settings at least you um you'll
have a check and you'll write out you
know 372 dollars and no sense or
whatever and then you write the digits
372 well one of the first applications
was automatically reading checks and
reading those digits three seven two
whatever from the thing that was written
by hand
um the uh but but an easier problem is
um actually a different application
which was an early one was uh uh reading
books for visually impaired folk where
you could take the book which is after
all printed and you could uh get it
recognized by a computer so the computer
could speak off the words that were in
the book
but so optical character recognition is
is vastly easier when you're dealing
with printed text because every a looks
more or less the same it may have
aligned itself differently with respect
to pixels and the ink may have you know
landed a little bit differently on the
paper but basically every a is the same
when it comes to handwriting that's not
the case when there are digits you have
a small enough number of digits to
choose from that you can start to
recognize things but if you're dealing
with ordinary handwriting in particular
words cursive and things like that it's
rather difficult and even today one has
not one doesn't really have systematic
ability to do character recognition on
handwritten stuff but you can on printed
stuff on printed stuff it's really good
so how does it work for printed things
so
what people did even from pretty early
on was you take the array of pixels that
corresponds to the a first of all you
have to kind of line up where is the
letter okay you've got the sort of
bounding box of this is where the letter
is you divide that region into pixels
and you say which of those pixels have
black ink which of them do not and then
you have to recognize given this pattern
of where the black ink is is that an a
is that a b is that a c Etc et cetera et
cetera actually this was a very early
application for neural networks uh
became uh even even in the 1960s I think
people were doing this of using uh sort
of what you were doing was basically
saying you've got an array of let's say
I don't know 100 pixels a 10 by 10 grid
of pixels and you say if this pixel is
on and that pixel is off and this pixel
is on and so on you've got all these
different combinations and you say with
this pattern which letter is it most
likely to be like and so so though was
this kind of scheme where you are using
one of these artificial neural Nets
where you're basically saying take one
particular pixel pixel number 17 or
something and then compare that with
pixel 18 and pixel 24 and then take the
first pixel with a weight 0.1 another
pixel with weight minus 0.2 another
pixel with 8.3 take the the Blackness or
whiteness as a one or zero multiply that
by the weight add all those numbers up
then say is the result let's say greater
than or less than zero
um and then make from those for each of
those kind of uh you're thinking of it
like a neuron in the brain one has uh a
given neuron will have dendrites that
kind of collect information from lots of
other neurons they're kind of like
little wires that are part of the nerve
cell and when those dendrites will be
sensing whether other nerve cells to
which they are connected have fired or
not so this is kind of an imitation of
that where you're saying uh you connect
these kind of uh these these things with
with weights and so on to these
different pixels and you say what
combination of pixels is on with what
weights and so on and then you you
simply learn typically when there's an a
these pixels with these weights will be
turned on and these ones will not be and
that's that's how from the very earliest
days of optical character recognition
that's pretty much how it worked
um and in modern times with modern deep
learning neural Nets we have many more
of these combinations of pixels and
weights and you have multiple layers
where you'll do one round of sort of
combining things with with weights and
so on and another round of that and
you'll do various kinds of thresholding
and so on
um it's possible to set it up so that if
you could only learn what the right
weights and connections and so on were
you could be very accurate in saying
that's an a that's a b and so on and the
the thing that is is now sort of
routinely done is training these neural
Nets in a systematic way where you say
let me show you a thousand examples of
A's a thousand examples of B's or or a
hundred thousand examples of values a
hundred thousand examples of bees and uh
you can
uh and based on those you can say the
A's tend to work this way the B's tend
to work that way you arrange these
weights and so on so that you can
discriminate between these different
kinds of kinds of letters now the more
different kinds of letters you're trying
to discriminate between the more
difficult it gets so for example it was
routine to deal with digits even
handwritten ones from by I would say the
1970s the um in terms of letters of the
alphabet the English alphabet for
example in books that was pretty routine
by the 80s
um in terms of sort of a a bigger sort
of discrimination problem is things like
don't just discriminate between letters
the English alphabet to all the Chinese
characters whatever it is some 10 some
of tens of thousands of them or
alternatively do you know like images of
cats and dogs and things and those are
things that only really became practical
um in in the last 10 or so years
um and that's sort of the the modern
machine learning uh
Revolution is associated with that
optical character recognition was
already doable before that all right
very long explanation about um about
different kinds of shapes of pixels and
so on but people did use hexagonal
pixels for some of the early optical
character recognition kinds of things
there's also some technologies for
flexible screens for example where you
can deform them you're not you're not
twist you're not distorting the shapes
of the pixels but you are certainly
taking what was kind of a nice ordinary
square and you are deforming it in the
third dimension and um not sure how
useful those things have yet turned out
to be but that's the technology that's
starting to be possible
let's see
uh
okay Auntie is asking why hasn't all the
cosmic background radiation escaped out
into the universe by now how is it still
around to be detected billions of years
later
okay this is kind of a tricky geometry
uh kind of thing okay so
the cosmic microwave background comes
from the close to the beginning of the
universe the universe started in this
kind of big bang where the universe
started as this ball of hot stuff
probably infinitely hot stuff
according to our recent Theory of
physics probably infinite dimensional
infinitely hot stuff
and gradually the temperature went down
the dimension went down and what was
happening was at the beginning the
universe was a bit like a star like the
sun you can't see into the Sun the the
photons that you see from the Sun are
all coming from the surface of the sun
inside the Sun photons are kind of
bouncing around and they're they're
gradually sort of moving around inside
the Sun they keep on getting scattered
by another another atom in the Sun or
another nucleus in the sun it takes like
I think 10 million years or something
for a photon to get on average from the
center of the Sun to the outside so the
sun is not transparent you don't get to
see into the Sun and you also don't get
to see into the cosmic into the Primeval
Fireball the initial uh thing in the Big
Bang all you can see is kind of the
surface of that well what happened is as
things cooled there came this moment
when the this hot gas became transparent
when it was hotter
than what some number of thousands of
degrees I forget exactly how many
um the
it was not transparent it's kind of like
a like a like fire or like the sun it's
something where uh photons of light keep
on getting scattered they can't they
can't just get through it as a
transparent thing but then sometime
around a hundred thousand years after
the beginning of the universe
the universe had cooled enough that it
was no longer the content of the
universe was no longer like fire or like
a star it was like ordinary gas that was
transparent and so all the photons that
we see the light the radiation that we
see comes from that moment when the
universe became transparent and we're
kind of seeing out to we're seeing to
the things the photons that were emitted
just before the universe became
transparent it's often called the last
scattering surface where they where the
the photons were were last scattered
before they just started moving freely
through the universe now of course they
don't move completely freely for the
through the universe because for example
a photon that started its Journey right
when the universe became transparent 100
000 years after the beginning of the
universe 14 and a half billion years
later it may be that you have a detector
that that detects that Photon so that
Photon has existed all that time all
that 14 billion years it's been just
traveling through the universe and then
splat it hits your detector and you
measure I saw that Photon so that's
what's happening when when you're
detecting something from the cosmic
microwave background now one question
you might ask is if that last scattering
surface if the temperature of things was
some number of thousands of degrees
maybe 6000 degrees or something how come
these and and it was something that
corresponded that that's a temperature
that corresponds to something like
visible light how come the photons that
we detect in the cosmic microwave
background are microwave photons that
have much lower energy
and the answer is that's because of the
expansion of the universe and it's
because the and this is where the
geometry gets kind of tricky
um you're let's see how best to explain
this
let's take a slightly different attack
here
let's say you're looking out into the
night sky
and you see a star in the sky and the
star is 10 light years away
that means that the light that hits your
eye that allows you to see that star
that light in some sense started its
Journey 10 years ago and it moved at the
speed of light from that star to your
eye and now you see it in your eye but
so that light is in a sense 10 year old
light coming from that star okay so now
let's look at a star further away well
they maybe you can look at a star that's
a billion light years away that means
that the light that comes to your eye
now started its Journey from that star a
billion years ago
okay let's keep looking further and
further you know it stars that are
further and further away eventually you
won't find any Stars anymore because
because you're asking for things that
were like 14 million years old 14
billion years ago that was a young
universe before any galaxies had formed
before there were any stars and what
you're seeing is right yeah a little bit
a little bit I think around that time
first galaxies were forming
um but you can look long enough ago that
there weren't any galaxies there weren't
any stars what do you see if you look
out into the night sky
um and you're you're seeing a thing that
was that old well the answer is you're
seeing back into that last scattering
surface you're seeing you're seeing the
Big Bang so to speak you're seeing the
the the place where the big bang the the
time when the Big Bang became
transparent but what do you see in each
different direction well the point is in
every direction you will see the big
bang and it's a little bit hard to
understand because you'd say well isn't
the Big Bang this thing that's that's um
that's sort of a lump in one place well
the point is that the lump in one place
we're sort of inside that lump and so
whenever we look sort of any in any
direction we will we will see to that
place where that uh initial
uh sort of primeval Fireball first
became transparent now it's not an
obvious fact that there are sort of
holes on the night sky where you get to
see all the way back to the Big Bang it
could be the case that every place you
look in the night sky there's a star or
a Galaxy right there could be the case
that that sort of on that there's let's
say that the galaxies were uniformly
distributed throughout the Universe then
it would be the case that pretty much
every direction you look in there will
be a very high chance that you would see
a Galaxy
turns out that galaxies are clumped as a
result of gravity and that's kind of why
there are holes you can kind of look
through so that you're basically seeing
past all the galaxies back to light that
started its Journey at the very
beginning of the universe or a hundred
thousand years after the beginning of
the universe so essentially what's
happening is that the um
uh when the the photons that were
produced in at the beginning of the
universe just got sent out in all
directions and some of those directions
are ones that leads to where we are in
the universe today and all those photons
they didn't the reason that they're
still out there in the universe is
because they didn't encounter anything
they went just as photons going on a
journey that lasted 14 billion years and
finally we detected them now an
interesting fact is because of
relativistic time dilation to that
Photon no time will seem to have passed
one of the features of Relativity is
that when an object is going very fast
the effective speed at which time passes
is progressively slower and if you're
going at the speed of light the speed at
which time passes is it doesn't pass at
all so to that Photon it's as if no time
passed it's like a as far as if the
photon which it can't
was kind of if it had some whole sort of
mind and and was thinking about what was
going on to the photon it would be like
I was just emitted
uh nothing happened oh I'm just absorbed
14 billion years later but no time will
have been perceived to pass
in in our Theory of physics we can kind
of understand in a rather mechanical way
why this time dilation process happens
see the thing is that a particle like a
photon or an electron all these things
are are created from kind of um sort of
structures in this giant kind of network
that represents the structure of space
and these particles it's like kind of
like a Vortex and a fluid for example
the the
it the vortex and the fluid it's kind of
like an Eddy that's going around but
there are molecules bouncing around if
you looked at a microscopic scale what
you're seeing in that Eddy is some
collective effect of lots of those
individual molecules bouncing around
well similarly we think particles like
electrons and photons are that same kind
of thing but instead of little molecules
bouncing around there's this network
that represents the underlying structure
of space
well when a particle kind of is
uh is in one place the particle that
that Network that represents the
structure of space is continually being
changed and a particle can either exist
at a particular place in space and
Progressive will be changed by the
updating of this network or the particle
might be moving and then the particle
has to essentially recreate itself in
different places in space at every
moment in time and the thing is that it
sort of uses a certain amount of
computational effort to recreate itself
at the same place but it is using if
it's moving it's using some of the
computational effort that it has some of
the computational capability it has it's
using to recreate itself at a different
place in space and so it doesn't have as
much sort of computational capability to
to sort of update itself in time so to
speak so if it's in one place it can use
sort of all of its computational
capability to just say I'm changing in
time I'm changing in time in this way if
it's also moving in space some of that
computational capability has to be to
recreate the particle in a different
place in space
so essentially that's why time slows
down if you're going faster because when
you go faster what that means is that
you're recreating yourself at a
different place in space and you're
using some of the sort of computational
ability that exists as a result of the
underlying structure of the universe
you're using some of that on motion and
you don't get to use as much of that on
the progress of time for a photon it's
an extreme case where you're kind of
using all of that computational ability
for motion you don't get to use any of
it for progression and time and that's
why it seems like no time has passed for
for something going at the speed of
light
let's see all right let's take a look at
some other uh questions that come in
here
um
www is pointing out it's weird to talk
about time experienced by a photon
um I say it experiences only two moments
of when it is produced and when it's
absorbed
interesting claim
so
uh
well it depends on the okay
if the thing that was there
was
let's say an atom has a nucleus a bunch
of electrons if it was even a proton
that has a bunch of quarks and gluons
and so on in it
when a proton is produced you're
producing this thing that is a you know
it's 10 to the minus 15 meters a
thousand trillionth of a meter across
but it's got a whole structure inside it
it's got we know that it has a structure
inside it and it consists of quarks and
gluons there are three basic quarks in a
proton and then there are lots of Quark
anti-cork pairs lots of gluons that's
continually sort of exchanging these
gluon particles that's that's kind of
holding the proton together but that
proton has a whole complicated structure
inside it we know that
and so it is the case that a proton that
you know when you take a proton and you
make the proton you accelerate it in a
particle accelerator to 99.99 of the
speed of light
that proton will experience less time
passing and I think experience is not
used so foolishly in the case of a
proton because the proton has all this
stuff going on inside so all those
quarks and they're interacting with
gluons and they're doing this and
they're doing that all those interaction
processes are happening sort of more
slowly at least as viewed by an observer
who isn't moving when there's a proton
going very fast
so I think it is fair to say that sort
of a proton when I say experience uh one
could interpret experience to mean sort
of the experience of a human-like
Observer kind of getting things into a
mind and so on I don't think we're we're
attributing quite the same type of thing
to that individual proton although I'm
not sure ultimately how different it is
but there are certainly things that are
happening inside the proton as a result
of of sort of the way the proton was
produced Etc et cetera et cetera
in the case of electrons and photons we
don't yet know whether they have an
inner structure in traditional physics
when I say traditional physics I mean
physics from the 20th century primarily
are the electrons are thought to be sort
of perfect geometrical points of zero
size
right now the um
uh we know that that electrons are
bigger than a uh they are
um
certainly not bigger than a millionth
the size of a proton but if you said
could they be a trillionth the size of a
proton we don't know
uh we don't know the the way that we get
to know how big we think electrons might
be is by crashing electrons into each
other and seeing how they scatter and we
know from those kinds of experiments
more or less it's those kinds of
experiments that um electrons certainly
can't be bigger than a millionth the
size of a proton maybe a 10 million of
the size of a proton but smaller than
that we don't know in our models of
physics electrons do have a non-zero
size it's pretty small it's like I think
10 to the minus 81 meters as I remember
is one estimate that I heard of it I
remember that number particularly
because when I was a kid I was
interested in particle physics and at
the time it looked like there were some
experiments in particle physics that
might have suggested that electrons were
not zero sized objects and I guess that
electrons might be 10 to the minus 18
meters which would be a thousandth the
size of a proton at the time one didn't
know that from experiments that turns
out not to be correct and so now sort of
the guess is it might be 10 to the minus
81 times meters rather than 10 to the
minus 18 meters or vastly vastly vastly
smaller but it's just kind of funny that
the digits are the same just reversed
but in our model of physics both
electrons and photons have non-zero size
uh they are they come from many
different pieces of the underlying
structure in the universe now I have to
say one of the things that I kind of
suspect is that the way that you get
something like an electron or a photon
it is made from the sort of tangle of
Connections in the underlying Network
that represents the structure of space
well other things that are made from
sort of the
structures that just exist in space are
black holes black holes are places in
the universe where gravity is strong
enough that it prevents kind of light
from escaping from some region and you
have this kind of deformation in the
structure of space that represents the
black hole black holes are pretty big at
least the ones that we know exist that
come from collapsing stars and so on are
big on the order of kilometers and
things like this
um in in size but
I kind of have the suspicion that in the
end it will turn out that one can look
at particles as being like very tiny
things very much like black holes and
one of the features of that is for for a
big black hole like a black hole that
might be uh something that we would
observe in a black hole Collision in the
gravitational wave detector or something
like this those black holes come from
the collapse of stars stars are a bit
more massive than the Sun but when a
black hole when something is as massive
of the sun collapses in as a result of a
supernova explosion or something like
this the um uh it can kind of fall in on
itself and be crushed by gravity and
eventually form a black hole but when it
falls in on itself like that you know if
there had been some civilization that
had a whole structure that was around
that star it probably would have been
pulled in by gravity and crushed into
the insides of that black hole so inside
a black hole there can be all kinds of
structure it may be kind of a mess in
there but there's there's all kinds of
structure in there outside a black hole
no light escapes from the black hole we
don't get to see anything about the
black hole other than just oh there's a
black hole there and it has certain
gravitational properties
so what that suggests is that when we
look at something like an electron one
of the big Mysteries actually in physics
is the fact that all electrons seem to
be the same
they're different in the sense that they
might be going in a different direction
at a different with a different energy
but all the electrons for example have
the same mass and um uh
and have um
um the uh uh and have that they all they
all seem to be the same and one feature
of black holes is that even though the
innards of the star that got crushed
might be completely different from
outside the black hole black holes look
the same except that they're except for
their size and how fast they're spinning
around
and so it's sort of a little bit like
with particles where all the electrons
look the same at least from the outside
because we're not on the inside of the
electron and so it could be the same
thing as happens with black holes that
sort of from the outside they're all the
same but from but there's an inside
where there can be all kinds of details
that are different and so uh that that
um sort of affects this you know what
can be happening inside the electron
well we won't know because we're on the
outside just like we were on the outside
of a black hole but there can still be
an inner structure that exists there in
some sense
uh
okay
let's see
okay William asks do you need mass in
order to store information can you have
an organism made purely out of photons
or other particles moving at the speed
of light interesting question I have a
friend who's a very
was a physicist then was in the
technology industry who
has this kind of I think slightly wacky
Theory
that um uh if you imagine this sort of
end point of a civilization that has
technology and all that kind of thing
that in the end the the way to kind of
exist for the longest time in the
evolution of the universe is in the form
of something like light and you know
just as I mentioned these photons can be
going for a very long time through the
universe you can imagine you turn sort
of the thoughts of a human into
something where it's just a bunch of
photons and so on and those photons are
traveling for a billion years through
the universe and maybe they finally hit
a grain of dust and they're then
scattered in some different direction
and so on so
my my friend has this sort of theory
that
um uh uh and I think he he kind of
relies on some things that I've done to
kind of argue that you could imagine
making a kind of universe-sized brain
out of essentially the exchange of of of
photons uh where where just like in our
brains you know one neuron will signal
on another neuron electric electrically
and takes a thousandth of a second for a
one neuron to Signal the the neighboring
neuron but you could imagine a situation
in which you're sort of signaling across
this giant brain that is the whole
universe and you're using light signals
and those light signals take a billion
years to arrive at the next sort of
place where they're going but um I don't
think
um one of the difficulties is okay
uh
let's see one of the problems is
that
if you have things going at the speed of
light
um
if you have two photons going in
opposite directions and they hit each
other you could ask what happens
well
in a first approximation with photons
they kind of just go through each other
but there's a very small probability of
what's called light by light scattering
which is a process by which the a photon
can interact with another photo actually
it happens by forming very briefly a
virtual electron positron pair and the
other Photon kind of interacts with the
electrical charge that was formed but in
that electron positron pair
um but
most of the time
you
it's kind of hard
to
well I think you end up with something
where let me think about this for a
second
um
yeah I mean the
it's hard to know how you build
something just out of light if you have
mirrors and you have light bouncing
around and so on that's all well and
good you can use light like you can
close electrons on a computer to
transmit information but you have to
have other stuff like the mirrors and so
on to to reflect the light if it's just
light you can ask the question could you
ever imagine even if you were prepared
to have things take a million years to
happen could you ever imagine making a
thing that was just made of light
and I think
well that's an interesting question
okay yeah I can think of a way you could
do it
um
if the light is traveling through
ordinary flat space
it's not going to work because you just
have a photo and it's just going and
it's trundling along unless it hits
something the photon's just going to
keep going in a straight line and those
parallel lines you'd have two photons
and they're both going in parallel lines
in flat space where there's no gravity
those photons will just never meet
okay however if there's gravity you can
have a situation where the space time is
curved and the paths of light are no
longer straight and for example in a
simple case one thing's been extensively
observed now is gravitational lensing
where if you have a mass like a Galaxy
or something you have photons that are
going near the Galaxy they will be bent
by the presence of a galaxy just like if
you send a spacecraft past a planet the
force of gravity from the planet will
cause the spacecraft to be deflected and
to sort of almost be pulled into the
planet well the same thing happens with
photons actually the the photons have
actually twice the effect that ordinary
particles have because they have
gravitational magnetism as well as
gravitational electrical like forces
they have gravitational magnetic light
forces that was a a big prediction of
Einstein's theory of General activity in
1915 was that the bending of light
around the sun will be by twice as much
as as it would have been in previous
theories and that was supposedly
observed not a very good experiment but
it was supposedly observed in 1919 it's
now been observed in much more detail
but that's what happens with
gravitational lensing is that the light
from a distant star is Bent by uh by the
presence of mass in a galaxy and it's
kind of like the Galaxy acts like a lens
sort of focusing light and so on okay so
the extreme version of that is in a
black hole uh particularly a spinning
black hole that can be photons that
actually orbit the black hole so they're
pulled in by the force of gravity of the
black hole so strongly that even though
they're going at the speed of light they
they can you can orbit in a black hole
you can orbit at the speed of light so
when you're orbiting the Earth you orbit
at 17 000 miles an hour when you orbit
the sun you're orbiting I don't know
what it is it's probably about
um sixty thousand miles an hour
something like that if you had an orbit
a a low Sun orbit close to the Sun you
probably get pretty hot there but every
different object of a certain mass and
size has some uh a certain orbital
velocity
for a spinning black hole the orbital
velocity is basically the speed of light
and so that means that you can actually
keep a photon in orbit around a black
hole
um and so I think it would be the case I
could imagine a situation in which you
could have photons that were orbiting a
black hole could have I mean this is
very exotic but photons orbiting a black
hole normally they would just pass
through each other without having an
effect but the thing I mentioned before
of Light by light scattering would
happen for those photons not a very high
rate a very low rate actually
um but it would occasionally it would
occasionally these photons would
interact with each other and so the
incredibly exotic kind of make a mind
make a computer out of something would
be a whole grid of photons all in orbit
around a black hole and uh all
interacting very slowly very
occasionally through light by light
scattering now one bug in this idea
might be that my recollection of the way
General Arts already works is that when
you have a rapidly spinning black hole
you can have this phenomenon of photons
being in orbit around it I don't think
you can have that for a black hole that
isn't spinning and so I think you need
the phenomenal frame dragging I think
you need that in order to get this orbit
of a photon around a black hole which
would mean that the photons could only
orbit around a rapidly spinning black
hole and they'd only orbit in the
direction that the the black hole is
spinning it would be like kind of if you
had satellites orbiting the Earth you
could only get the geostationary
satellites though that are orbiting you
know right over the equator of the Earth
in in synchrony with the with the motion
of the earth you wouldn't be able to
have the polar orbits and so on so I'm
not quite sure how that works for a
black hole and it may not work out but
if you could have orbits that were not
purely sort of on the equator of the
black hole then then you could do this
thing that I'm mentioning of having this
kind of bizarre grid of photons that
we're interacting by light by light
scattering an incredibly exotic kind of
idea of how to make a computer and
something that would be an incredibly
inefficient and slow way to compute
things but that would be a way in which
you could basically have something that
is a a computer or mind like thing made
purely out of photons at least that's
that's my most immediate um uh
um
version of that yeah Acer comments black
holes all that sounds like most powerful
particle accelerator yep yes it is I
mean it's uh you know a way that a lot
of high energy astrophysical phenomena
occur is you have a a thing that's very
massive and you'll have things that are
pulled into orbit around that thing and
as they get pulled in they get
accelerated and so for example when when
Mata is kind of getting sucked into a
black hole it will orbit very quickly it
will orbit so quickly that for example
it will emit things like X-rays and so
on just as uh when you have something a
Charged particle like an electron is
moving and being held in an orbit it
will emit uh well it will emit radio
waves and it will emit visible light if
it's going faster eventually X-rays and
so on and yes that happens and yes you
can use uh there are high energy
astrophysical phenomena that are
believed to be associated with matter
getting pulled into sort of spiraling
into black holes and so on
let's see
um
well
um
let's see
ah this is a question from Aaron does
time move faster for hotter objects
Ah that's a mess
um
well
the answer is no
but
the problem is
um
okay
in the sort of the basic setup of
Relativity Theory there is special
alternative from 1905.
it's based on the following observation
that
the speed of light however fast you're
moving
you
when you emit light the light always
goes at the speed of light relative to
you
so
for example
if
you're dealing with sound waves
a sound wave is a wave of compression
and rare fraction in the air
a sound wave is is sort of a feature
it's something that is kind of locked in
to the air in the room so if we've got
air in this room and on average the air
in this room is stationary the
individual molecules yeah they're moving
around very rapidly but on average there
are as many molecules moving left as
moving right on average the air in this
room is stationary so when a sound wave
goes through the air the sound wave is
is always kind of it moves at the speed
of sound relative to the air so if I'm
moving quickly through the air and I'm
speaking for example the sound wave I
produce is still going to go at the
speed of sound relative to the air
relative to being stationary not at the
speed of sound relative to me the moving
me if I was moving at 100 miles an hour
for example and going yak yak yak the
sound wave I produce will still go at uh
you know whatever it is 550 miles an
hour relative to the
relative to the stationary air in the
room not relative to me and that's why
for example when when an airplane goes
faster than speed of sound all those
sound waves kind of pile up because it's
producing sound waves it's it's making a
sound as goes through the air but those
sound waves they they the the the
they're moving only at the speed of
sound relative to the stationary air not
at the speed of sound relative to the
airplane okay so the big observation
that launched relativity is that in the
Maxwell equation Maxwell's equations for
electromagnetism were invented in the
1870s
um in those equations it is the case
that however fast you're moving if you
emit light
the light will be going at the speed of
light relative to you
and so
that idea
is like how can this be because
if that's the case how does it manage to
be the case that how does that all work
out because if you're moving quickly and
you know how can it and and you're
emitting light how can that light be
still going at the speed of light
relative to you even if you were
yourself going at half the speed of
light and so what what Einstein figured
out is that if you change the definition
of length and time everything can work
out just fine
and and so uh the um and so what happens
is time is dilated I mentioned that uh
space is contracted if if those things
happen then you maintain the consistency
of uh of the speed of light is constant
for an observer in any state of motion
now the way this works in our theories
of physics maybe I shouldn't get into
this it all has to do with causal graphs
and so on it's rather rather lovely
um how one ends up with that same
situation in these kind of systems where
one is continuously rewriting the
structure of spaces and so on okay why
does this have anything to do with
temperature and hot objects
well the problem is that the definition
of temperature is
the temperature is associated with the
motion of all those little molecules for
example in a room the faster the
molecules are going it's the average
energy of those molecules as they run
around that defines temperature and and
so in order to have a notion of
temperature you need to have a kind of a
a an extended material like a gas for
example and you then you could say the
gas is this temperature the gas is that
that temperature
um and and it has to have things that
bounce around it has to have walls and
it has to be sort of enclosed in some
way you don't really get to say that
individual electron has a temperature
that doesn't really mean anything it's
it's you could say that individual
electron has a certain energy and that
energy is the average energy for things
bouncing around at a certain temperature
but you have to have this whole notion
of things bouncing around and a whole
collection of different
um uh of different um uh pieces in order
to in order to really Define an ocean
temperature okay so the problem is that
if you are using kind of Relativity
Theory and so on the theory of what
happens to Extended objects is pretty
complicated
let me give you an example I actually
just found I've been looking at a bunch
of work that I did many many years ago
and I had an unfinished paper that I
wrote in
1983 I think
um which was called realistic
relativistic matter and that paper was
supposed to be about
the question of what is it really like
to have matter like a solid object or a
gas for that matter and have it go at
this you know at something close to the
speed of light what is that really like
for example a solid object how does it
work when it goes close to the speed of
light let me give you an example of why
things get really screwy
so let's imagine you have a solid object
you say it's all good I've got a solid
object I've got this this big pole and
it's a long pole and it's a solid and I
start spinning this pole around and so
at the center I'm just I'm just spinning
the Polish at rate the center of the
pole that the the place where I'm
spinning it and that's going you know
pretty fast but not so fast as you go
further and further out on the pole the
pole is going to be going faster and
faster and faster until eventually the
tip of the pole will be going faster
than speed of light so how does this
work because we've got a solid object
that's supposed to be a a rigid solid
thing we're turning it slower than speed
of light in the middle but by the time
you're far out it's going faster than
the speed of light what does it actually
do
so what actually what it actually does
is the pole falls apart in other words
this stresses the internal stresses on
the pole eventually become if the pole
was going to be eventually going if the
tip was going to be going eventually
faster than the speed of light or at the
speed of light there would be infinite
stresses in the pole so any material
object will fall apart if you try and
make it go close to the speed of light
so it becomes very difficult to Define
what you mean by material objects when
you deal with things going close to the
speed of light and so on and so this
question it's actually a long time
question when you have a length for
example or time these both transform
relativistically in the sense that if
you go to certain velocity so you go to
a fraction well the usual symbol used as
beta a fraction beta of the speed of
light okay then there's just a formula
that says that if you go a beta the
speed of light it's
um the uh the 4 formula for the the rate
of time you know one unit of time is
then one over the square root of one
minus beta squared that's just the
formula in relativity Theory
um uh if I had kind of a thing I was
drawing on I could probably even explain
why the formula works out that way it's
a really quite simple geometrical
argument in the end
um it has to do with essentially a right
angle triangle
um and uh that that's the um that's the
side length on the right angle triangle
that's square root of well it's what at
least the the denominator the square
root of Y minus beta squared is that so
in any case the um
uh oh actually no it's it's the it's
it's one of the side Links of the if the
hypotenuse is one that's what that's
what you get for on the side lengths so
so anyway the the um uh the thing that
um
uh
uh what's the point the the something
like length transforms relativistically
according to that formula same with time
for reasons that I don't think were
clear before our recent physics project
energy transforms like time and momentum
transforms like lengths the fact that
those things were an exact
correspondence
um in the way they transformed
relativistically is something that's
easy to understand from our model of
physics I actually looked at what
Einstein said about why they transformed
the same way and he just says well we'll
just assume they do this he doesn't
really offer an explanation for why the
transformation should be the same so the
next question is well how does
temperature transform so let's say you
have and by the way I I should say that
one of the features of the
transformational length and time is that
essentially as you go at a speed close
to the speed of light you're kind of
trading off length and time you're
you're going further in length less far
in time these these kinds of things
there's a definite kind of trade-off
that happens okay so for temperature how
does temperature transform
relativistically
basically nobody knows that that's not a
very well defined it's not a thing
that's where there's a good clean theory
of what happens it's something where if
you have this box of gas and you move it
at a high speed well you've got all
these assumptions about oh how what
happens to the to the um uh what happens
to the the sort of the the container of
the gas what happens if the uh when you
have an extended object and you're
looking at that extended object you see
it by light coming from the different
parts of that object to you and so all
kinds of weird things happen like if you
have a cube going close to the speed of
light the cube will appear to be rotated
because the further away parts of the
cube
um the light comes to you it takes
longer to get to you and so on
um so a lot of weird effects associated
with an extended material object going
at something close to the speed of light
so it's not really clear how temperature
forms so this question of whether there
is a
relativistic temperature change
um gosh it's really hard to say because
because you're moving the whole object
and it's it's hard to say I don't I
don't really know quite how to
unscramble that now when it comes to
Extended objects moving close to the
speed of light this was something we've
studied for a long time and uh back in
the 1960s and so on and one of the kind
of extended objects were strings so that
what people imagined was you have this
this one-dimensional thing this kind of
piece of string and it's moving at the
speed of light and it's kind of wobbling
around as a string but the string uh
sort of has this world sheet as it's
called if you look at the space-time uh
thing that is this sort of um uh carved
out by this moving string it's this kind
of sheet in space time and so people try
to get kind of a consistent theory of
how strings would would move
um at the speed of light as extended
objects and it turns out to be a very
complicated story and that is the origin
that's one of the origins of string
theory and there are many consistency
conditions about when these strings
really move in a consistent way and have
motion that works consistently and
that's what ends up with string theory
needing to be in like 26 dimensional
space in order to avoid inconsistencies
associated with the way that these
extended string objects move in physical
space so the whole theory of extended
objects in relativity is really a
complicated thing and there are even the
special case of the string moving uh
relativistically that hope that story is
already sort of ends up turning into the
the story of string theory so it's a
very complicated mathematical structure
and it becomes very difficult you know
in the case of string theorem just says
imagine there's a string like this but
um uh in the case of just sort of
talking about an extended object you
know an imaginary spacecraft traveling
very close to the speed of light it's
made of you know whatever the spacecraft
is made of metal or something like this
it um uh it becomes difficult to
describe what will happen as a practical
matter in in many kinds of situations
the metal will always fall apart because
metal has only you know the metal has
only a certain fixed uh amount of force
between the atoms that holds it together
but the result of kind of gravitational
of the forces that are associated with
with motion close to the speed of light
will necessarily be greater than
anything that that holds the thing
together by by forces between the atoms
so complicated answer
um
let's see
ah William observes doesn't a black hole
have a temperature what happens to black
hole's entropy okay the
uh all right
let's see if I can do this the
um
okay
a temperature
is normally associated with average
kinetic energy of particles bouncing
around so you have particles of gas in a
box you heat it up what's happening is
the walls of the Box are getting hotter
they have molecules bouncing around
faster every time a gas molecule hits
the wall it might get a little kick of
energy from one of the particles in the
wall and so it goes a bit faster and
then pretty soon the molecules and the
gas are going at a higher speed so
that's the ordinary definition of
temperature
okay so you can also just say imagine
uh well you could
yeah that's the ordinary definition of
temperature
just sort of particles bouncing around
with a certain average kinetic energy
okay black holes
here's a tricky thing about black holes
usually black holes just
everything that gets near a black hole
gets pulled into the black hole the
gravity of the black hole just pulls it
in and as soon as it goes past the Event
Horizon of the black hole you on the
outside of the black hole never get to
see it again
now things are a bit tricky as they
usually are in relativity something that
is going to fall into a black hole for
you as an outside Observer you'll always
see it hovering on the edge of the Event
Horizon to you as an outside Observer
you'll never actually see it go into the
Event Horizon that takes an infinite
time
um to you as an outside Observer but in
any case conceptually it's as if the
thing falls into the Event Horizon for
the thing itself it will in its time
fall through the Event Horizon but time
is dilated for the Observer at a
distance relative to The Observer who's
actually falling into the black hole
Okay so
anyway so now first approximation
everything falls into a black hole okay
or everything that didn't have that term
uh
yeah so okay now here's where things get
tricky
in Quantum field Theory
the
um
uh
the vacuum
okay so this is actually a bit clearer
in our models of physics than it has
been in traditional Quantum field Theory
but let me explain the traditional
Quantum field Theory case which is what
people usually talk about when they talk
about black hole temperatures and black
hole entropies and so on
so
what uh
what happens is
you think you've got a vacuum where
there are zero particles but the way
quantum mechanics works you never get to
have a certainty of anything so in fact
even in the vacuum there are always
these particle anti-particle pairs that
are forming and then annihilating again
forming analytic again very quickly
these are so-called virtual particles
that just come into existence for a very
short time and then are destroyed again
and so in the vacuum everywhere in space
in the vacuum in standard one field
Theory you have an infinite collection
of these particle antiparticle pairs
being produced and then annihilating
again in our Theory of physics by the
way that process of the particles coming
into existence being destroyed again
there is energy associated with those
particles and one of the problems in
traditional physics has been that that
energy produces a gravitational force
that will curl the universe up into a
tiny ball so it's been very obscure why
that doesn't make the universe basically
tiny well in our Theory of physics
what's happening is that the structure
of space
is being sort of knitted together by
these rewritings of this network that on
a very small scale is what what space is
made of so to speak and those rewriting
events both produce space
and represent those virtual particle
anti-particle pairs so in a sense the
whereas in traditional physics space is
just put in there and then we have the
virtual particle antibodical person
happening on on top of space in our
model space is made from essentially the
same process that is that virtual
particle antiparticle pair uh process
got that's going on so but in any case
the basic point is
however you look at it there's these
virtual particle antiparticle powers are
getting formed all over the vacuum all
over space so what happens if that
happens right at the Event Horizon of a
black hole what can happen is there are
two members of that particle
antiparticle pair the particle that's an
electron and the antibiotic or positron
let's say if you align things up just
right the positron might fall into the
black hole and it was going to
annihilate with the electron but it
never gets to do that because that
positron got lost inside the black hole
and so the electron is stuck on its own
and that electron just sort of appears
as a thing that sort of emerges from the
black hole and so Stephen Hawking back
in 1972-ish had this calculation of how
that would work I have to say I wasn't
at all sure that that calculator if it
was late in that 76 I think maybe even
um that um uh yeah yeah because it was I
was already doing physics stuff by that
time the the um um
I certainly wasn't sure that that
calculation was actually right and then
it got done in many many different ways
and nobody's actually observed the
Hawking radiation from a black hole but
it's something that uh is is it looks
pretty solid there are lots of different
ways of calculating it they all seem to
give the same answer now uh the the
thing that's mysterious
well okay this is again rather
complicated but but um uh
the fact that these sort of electrons
just sort of come out of the black hole
and so on kind of doesn't feel right for
quantum mechanics
quantum mechanics has this idea of oh
there's an electron there's a positron
they're very coherent with each other
they're very sort of fundamentally
correlated and um the uh
um
and that uh that coherence
is called a broken by the presence of
the Event Horizon of the black hole and
so it's always been a bit mysterious how
that works how you get it's the
so-called information Paradox the black
holes that you can end up with something
where there's sort of a a Quantum
coherent thing but then the black hole
forms and then that Quantum coherence is
somehow broken
well okay what happens in our models is
ah this is this is going to get too
weird
um
there is not just one Event Horizon in a
black hole there's an event horizon in
physical space and there's also an event
horizon in what we call branchial space
which is essentially the space of
quantum branches and let me not try and
explain that in detail right now let's
take take a little while to explain that
but the basic point is that
just as
I mentioned that in physical space to an
outside Observer
the
um
uh
this kind of any particle that's going
to fall into the black hole appears to
be sort of Frozen right at the edge of
the black hole right at the edge of the
Event Horizon for an infinite time
well one of the things that will happen
is that not only will that particle be
frozen but also
the
if you have kind of a
a a Quantum measurement
something which is trying to decide
whether a particular Quantum process
happened or didn't happen a measurement
a Quantum measurement that will also get
Frozen and so kind of the the image of
it is that the Observer who is trying to
observe what happens with this black
hole will be stuck essentially
um uh
not as one could put it not sort of
being able to form
um a um uh sorry one second
um the
um not uh not being able to sort of form
a classical thought that the Observer
just like the the sort of particle
appears Frozen in space so an observer
their sort of thought processes will be
frozen in the same way and so it turns
out you can sort of resolve this this
this Paradox of oh is it quantum is it
not how does that work by thinking in
those kinds of terms but um uh let's see
what was the the original uh question
um
about uh
oh my what was I even answering here I
got the oh black hole temperature yes so
okay so what happens is
black holes because of this process of
you know vacuum fluctuations one part of
the vacuum fluctuation is pulled in
through gravity inside the black hole
the other one escapes that causes black
holes to produce a certain amount of
emission of radiation which turns out to
be radiation that is distributed in the
same frequency distribution as when
light is emitted from a hot object
so-called black body radiation
and what happens is as black hole gets
smaller and smaller the intensity of
radiation and Method gets higher and
higher and so the expectation is that
black holes that um will gradually get
sort of eaten up but for a big black
hole the rate of radiation is absolutely
tiny as the black hole gets smaller and
smaller the rate of radiation gets
faster and faster until eventually the
black hole will kind of disappear in a
blaze of radiation and for black holes
if there were black holes that were
about the mass of Mount Everest that had
been created in the early Universe
they'd be kind of exploding like that
right around now we haven't seen any of
such explosions but who knows
um I think in our models of physics
there are some additional things there's
a thing that I was calling the black
hole wind which is kind of this process
where you get essentially gravitational
radiation emitted as a there's a Quantum
gravitational effect that you have
um essentially gravitational radiation
being emitted by a black hole when black
holes merge what's been observed by the
gravitational wave detectors is the very
intense emission of gravitational waves
when when black holes merge and for
example
um you know the the first black hole
merger an amount of mass about the mass
of the Sun was destroyed in a matter of
a few seconds and turned into
gravitational radiation so hugely
intense amount of gravitational
radiation this black hole wind that I'm
talking about is a very light amount of
gravitational radiation okay one comment
about entropy
um I was literally doing something on
this this afternoon actually
um okay so entropy
is this idea
that has various tentacles but its basic
idea is if you've got a thing a
configuration of gas you've got all
kinds of molecules in a box and of gas
the entropy is counting the number of
possible configurations of those
molecules that are consistent with
saying I've got a trillion molecules in
a one centimeter Cube box the molecules
can be going this way they can be going
that way they can be arranged in
different ways but what you can do is
count the number of ways they can be
arranged and you take that number you
take its logarithm then that gives you
the entropy of the gas so the logarithm
is saying if you say let's say you had
uh just a collection of particles in
each particle could either be in an up
position or a down position and let's
say you have you have three particles
they can each be either up or down then
the number of possible overall
configurations is like up up up up down
up down down up down up et cetera et
cetera et cetera there are eight
possible configurations and in general
if you have n things that can be either
up or down there are two to the power n
2 times 2 times 2 N times
um possible configurations of that whole
object and so the logarithm
for example log to the base 2 of 2 to
the N is just n the logarithm is just
telling you the exponent it's telling
you the the number of times you multiply
things so when you have particles in a
box essentially every particle you add
it gets to decide what it does and it's
kind of multiplying the number of
possible configurations of all the
existing particles so by taking that
logarithm you'll roughly counting the
number of particles the number of
degrees of freedom that the system has
and so entropy is always this count of
the number of degrees of freedom that a
system has that are consistent with some
constraint that you've given on the
system like you say it's a box that's
one centimeter across it's a box that's
two centimeters across it's this
material that has is made from these
where the molecules are arranged this
way it's a material where the molecules
are arranged that way the entropy is the
number of degrees of freedom the number
of different of independent things you
can change consistent with the
constraints that you give
okay so does space-time have an entropy
well in our model of physics it does
because in our model of physics space is
made from this giant network of of of of
points of elements and so if you say
well I've got a box of space I've got a
region of space and it's this size we
can just count the number of possible
kind of webbings the number of possible
networks that are consistent with a box
of space of that size now it's a little
tricky because the actual structure of
space determines one's notion of size
there's a bit of fancy footwork there
which which actually I don't completely
know how to do yet
um but roughly you can simply count the
number of configurations of the network
and that gives you effectively you can
use that to compute the entropy of a of
a box of space
okay now usually it's a little bit hard
to know what you mean by a box of space
the one case where that's not hard to
figure out is black hole because a black
hole is a well-defined Event Horizon
that says this is a region of space
that's inside this region that's outside
and so on so a bit of a cliffhanger here
because I don't actually know how to
compute the entropy in our models for a
black hole hopefully somebody will
figure out how to do that and my guess
is I'm fairly certain that the answer
will be the same as the answer that one
gets from the calculation that deduces
entropy from temperature from this black
hole Hawking radiation and so on but so
the idea of the entropy of a black hole
is to say what are the number of
configurations of the structure of space
consistent with the fact that there's a
black hole there and there may be many
different configurations of space that
all lead to that same structure of the
Event Horizon
just like there are many different
configurations of the gas that all say
oh there's just gas molecules enclosed
in this box now that's that's a very uh
new
kind of our multiple of physics
explanation of black hole entropy I
think it is I think it's right and I
think it's much clearer than what's been
known before what's been known before is
kind of a very indirect circuitous path
where you deduce the entropy from
knowing things about the radiation but I
think you can say it quite directly and
that's what it's due to is that the
black hole I mentioned before that sort
of all black holes look the same they're
defined just by their mass and their
their spin rate their angular momentum
but that's not strictly the case when
you get up to quantum gravity then you
it will not be the case I think that all
black holes will be the same instead
they will be uh there'll be many
possible things that have that same mass
and and spin rate and that that those
that count of the number of such things
will give the entropy of the black hole
um
oh boy there's there's some
uh
mean asks why doesn't the black hole
filler collapse in and itself
um
because this picture is kind of a
mechanical collapse isn't really the
correct Story the correct story is that
uh well the main story is
okay
in the simplest kind of black hole at
the center of the black hole
are in traditional theories of gravity
there is a space-time Singularity at
which the curvature of space is infinite
and what does that mean well when you
have an object it's in space if it's in
flat space the object just sits there if
the space gets curved the object is
essentially deformed by the curvature of
space and so when you have an event a a
not an event horizon that's this is
inside their Enterprise and there's a
singularity in space-time at that
Singularity space time is infinitely
deformed so any object that you have is
itself infinitely deformed so that's the
traditional view in general relativity
in our models of space uh that
Singularity which is usually has to be
something that is described not with the
standard equations of General activity
of the theory of gravity because those
equations can't describe a singular
place they can only describe continuous
changes in the structure of space in our
models you can describe things which
change discontinuously like that because
the whole model is based on a discrete
structure of space and our models in
that kind of black hole what happens is
that this network that represents space
gets to a place where it just freezes
there are no more updates that can
happen on this network so what that
means is that time stops because time is
the progressive updating of the network
the network represents everything in the
universe the progress of time in the
universe is the process of updating that
Network so at the center of the simplest
kind of black hole what happens is the
network can no longer be updated there
and so time just stops
so if you were approaching that
Singularity what would happen is you
would just freeze forever you just time
would stop and um so
that's kind of what happens in in the
black hole is eventually just time stops
so there's nothing more that can happen
it's you're done because time has
stopped and that's a that's a rough
explanation I mean the the story of why
the Event Horizon uh is of a certain
size and so on is a slightly more
complicated story uh see it's a simple
way to explain that
um
not that I can immediately come up with
uh but but that's that's some version of
why the black hole can't further
collapse
usam asks do the updates to maintain the
structure space explain vacuum energy
yes they do so vacuum energy is this
phenomenon that in the vacuum because of
these particle antiparticle pairs
there's an infinite energy associated
with the vacuum and maybe it isn't
completely infinite but it's very high
at least
and our model where the actual processes
going on in the vacuum are what create
the structure of space explain that
phenomenal vacuum energy because really
what you're doing is you're just looking
at things relative to the space that we
think of as being there so the fact that
the space that we think of as being
there has all the stuff that we might
think of as energy associated with it is
irrelevant to us because all we all we
are sensitive to is changes relative to
the structure of space as we know it so
that sort of that that explains and gets
rid of this kind of long-time problem in
physics of the fact that there's this uh
huge vacuum energy that exists
everywhere in the universe
maybe one more
question and then I should wrap up here
um
well Prometheus are so much more complex
of the Dynamics of the human brain than
the Dynamics of a galaxy you know it's a
funny thing I think we know now that
there are what about 86 billion neurons
I think in a typical human brain so give
or take 100 billion neurons in a typical
human brain turns out there are also 100
billion stars in the typical Galaxy
there are also 100 billion galaxies in
the universe so there's a there's a lot
of that number 100 billion shows up in a
bunch of places so if you're going to
remember kind of a number about about
sort of science or something that
hundred billion number number of stars
in the galaxy number of galaxies in the
universe number of neurons in a brain
they're all about the same and um
you know to assess sort of
the question of what's more complicated
than what sort of depends on asking well
what is it that you care about about
what's happening if you care only about
the Motions of stars and you don't care
about all those all those aliens that
are hanging out on all those planets
around all those Stars doing all this
cool stuff you only care about the
motion of stars then you've just got 100
billion stars in the galaxy but if you
care about all those aliens doing cool
stuff then there's a lot more detail and
there's a lot more going on there
similarly in brains if all you care
about is well we don't know exactly what
you should care about in brains there's
a lot of fine detail of individual
molecules you know proteins getting
produced in the synapses and brains and
so on we don't know how much of that
stuff matters and how much it's just
they're the neuron fire or did it not
fire and and that's um that's kind of
the uh uh
the the sort of the the you know what
level of detail are you looking at is
important to understand and assessing
that um that difficulty
uh
okay that's made of us does a black hole
inherit the dimensionality of the
space-time it's forming in
um
well okay in traditional theories of
gravity in the Einstein equations which
are the usual equations used to the um
to describe uh the structure of space
and time
um the uh those Einstein equations you
you have to pick the dimension of space
time before you start so there's three
plus one dimensional space time three
space one time that's ordinary space for
us
in things like string theory one might
look at you know 10 dimensional space
time and so on there are there are
Einstein equations that you can write
down for any number of dimensions of
space time and um the uh uh usually time
is just one dimension effectively and
space is all the other dimensions
but um the uh
um
but so you get to pick an integer a
whole number and that's the number of
dimensions of space
in our models of physics that's not the
way it works because space is formed
from this kind of large-scale limit of
this underlying Network you can end up
with a dimension of space that isn't
necessarily three it could be 3.1 it
could be something where see okay how do
you how do you estimate the dimension of
space from just if all you know is
points in space how do you figure out
what the dimension of space is so you
just got this big bag of points in space
and all you know is what point is sort
of is connected to what other point what
point is related to what are the points
so where you can figure out the
dimension of space is by just saying
start at a point go to all its neighbors
then go to all its neighbors neighbors
then keep going and ask how many points
do you get to by progressively going to
the neighbors the neighbors of the
neighbors the neighbors of the neighbors
and the neighbors okay let's say all the
points were arranged on a square grid
okay so we start at one point and then
we go to its neighbors there it might be
four neighbors NorthEast Southwest we go
to their four neighbors if you're
imagining it you're making this kind of
diamond shape the number of neighbors
that you go to goes up like the area of
a square so so it goes up like like r
squared if R is the distance you've gone
imagine a line how many neighbors do you
get to well you always have a linear
number it just goes up like oh you've
just gone a distance R you've just
extended your three steps to the left
three steps to the right the total
number of things you reach is
proportional to R so in general as you
on on a grid for example like let's say
a three-dimensional grid do the same
calculation you'll find it's R cubed
okay but but if you just imagine that
all you have is points elements nodes
and connections you can do the same
calculation but the calculation has no
reason to end up being having an answer
where the growth rate is an integer
whether where the exponent the r to the
power D where the D is an integer
so in our models of of space you can
have a variable Dimension space and you
can have space whose Dimension changes
over time like we think the early
Universe had infinite dimensional space
which gradually kind of cooled down to
be three-dimensional in the universe
that we experienced today so in our
models of physics it's possible to have
Dimension change the standard theories
of of space-time simply don't know how
to deal with anything other than integer
dimensional space there is no Theory
there nobody knows what the Einstein
equations are like in 3.1 dimensional
space the only way we know anything
about that is from our models of physics
and we're starting that one of our
projects in the next few months and our
Wolfram Institute is to try and do the
kind of generalization of calculus
that's needed to be able to work out how
one thinks about sort of the
generalization of kinds of structures of
space outside of integer dimensions
so uh the answer is for a black hole in
ordinary Einstein gravity or the
ordinary equations of gravity you first
have to pick
the dimension of space and then you make
up your equations and in different
numbers of Dimensions there are
different kinds of black hole structures
so for example in um uh in three
dimensions of space one dimension of
time uh you have the ordinary black hole
you have a non-spinning black hole you
have a spinning black hole when you go
to different dimensions I think in
four dimensions of space so five
dimensions of space uh you get these
things that are called black Saturns
which are things that have sort of a
central black hole that are like the
black holes we have in three
three-dimensional space but they also
have this kind of Saturn's rings like
other black thing that sort of a Taurus
around the main black hole that doesn't
happen the structure of the Event
Horizon doesn't isn't like that in the
case of well a spinning black hole even
in three dimensions of space has a more
complicated structure it's the so-called
curved solution to the Einstein
equations and it has an inner Event
Horizon an outer Event Horizon and it
has a lot of exotic stuff that goes on
and you can have exotic things where
there's a crossover between an inner
black hole and a white hole all kinds of
exotic things it's all happening inside
an event horizon you don't get to report
on it well more or less people thought
that the singularity that could exist at
the center of a black hole could never
be naked it could never be without an
event horizon turns out there's an
elaborate construction that you can make
that allows you to form a naked
singularity in three in ordinary
Einstein gravity that that formation of
a naked Singularity is a very it's a
very elaborate delicate process you have
to be adding a little piece of matter
here a little piece there a little piece
there you've got to make sure nothing
bad happens you add these things in
exactly the right way and you'll get a
naked Singularity it's kind of a little
bit like if you want to reduce the
temperature of an object to absolute
zero where all the molecules are
essentially stationary uh because you've
taken all the heat out of the system
that's something it takes a lot of
effort you have to say that molecule oh
yeah let's zap that one oh yeah let's
zap that one it becomes increasingly
difficult to do that as you want to get
to absolute zero and it's the same thing
if you want to form a naked Singularity
I don't know what the actual uh
structure of naked singularities is
outside of three plus one dimensional
space time I would imagine the same
constructions work they might get easier
in higher Dimensions I'm not sure it
might get harder as well well because I
can I can imagine Arguments for both
things and I don't know don't know the
answer to what happens and I'm not sure
if it's known but in any case outside of
three dimensions there are different
kinds of Singularity structures that can
exist different kinds of event Horizons
that can exist what those look like in
like 3.1 dimensional space we don't yet
know we'd like to know in fact that will
be a that will be if it turns out
actually I hadn't thought of this before
yeah if it turns out so one of the
things that's of great interest in our
models is to try and detect Dimension
fluctuations in the universe and we
think there might be a way of doing that
by detecting what a dimension
fluctuation does to a photon from a
cosmic microwave background
but it occurs to me that if something
funky happens with the event Horizons of
black holes it could be the case that a
black hole formed very early in the
universe would be formed in a region of
space-time that was still sort of a
fluctuating region of space-time that
had dimension 3.01 for example and
wasn't you know wasn't really close to
three dimensions and it could be the
case that there is some exotic effect
that comes from the formation of a black
hole in 3.01 dimensional space-time
which right now we have no idea how that
works I mean in our models we can
simulate it numerically with a small
number of of uh of of Elementary
elements in Space the real number of
Elementary elements in space is
absolutely huge but we can do a computer
simulation for a small number and we can
kind of see what happens and that's an
interesting idea that perhaps if there
is some kind of anomalous behavior of a
black hole in just away from
three-dimensional space and that could
have have an effect of gravitational
lensing for example effect that could be
visible in gravitational lensing from
very early in the history of the
universe so that's an interesting idea
thank you all implicitly for for
providing that um that idea because
we're really interested in you know
what's the microscope that allows one to
see down to that microscopic structure
of space just like when we're looking at
a fluid like water how do you know it's
made of molecules well there are these
exotic experiments like Brownian motion
where you have a you know you see a
pollen grain being kicked around we need
to find the analogous exotic experiments
that give us this this way of seeing
what happens in uh in physical space and
seeing down to the kind of molecular
structure of physical space
um
the uh
uh okay it's a comment here about some
um
William says the number of atoms in a
bacterium is also about 100 billion
that's interesting I didn't know that
let me see can I estimate that
a bacterium is like a micron across I
think
and
that would be so that is one micro meat
one micrometer if I'm right about that
and that would be 10 to the minus 18
cubic meters and uh
then the number of
um in that volume
if it's density one which it probably
isn't but let's say it is that that the
that would be 10 to the minus 18 grams
and that would be so the number of uh
molecules in a bam is 6 times 10 to the
26 so let's see that's about um now
we're getting roughly that number I'm
not quite sure if it's Landing quite in
the right place
um oh boy William is you see this is
something I'm I'm pretty sure if you
type into wolf Mal for 100 billion
meters 100 billion atoms and things it
better give comparisons that start
listing these off I better try that
that's a good um
um that's a good good suggestion here uh
all right one last thing here
um
let's see
the doctor says as gravity increases and
or speed increases time is constant of
participant but on the outside space and
distance can be greater or lesser if you
had a light year cube of space and
shrunk it into a meter
light would take the same time to go
through it
well how do you shrink that light year
of space I mean that's that's the issue
I mean I think um uh the um
um
the this question about sort of
expanding and Contracting space that's a
very weird concept because we're in
space
right and and so let me just mention one
thing you know people say the universe
expands say So What on earth does that
mean if everything in the universe
expands how do we know that anything is
expanding because we'd be expanding too
in fact in our models of physics it is
possible that the universe is expanding
everywhere at an incredibly rapid rate
and that at every moment in time we are
made from more and more and more atoms
of space we're expanding rapidly but we
don't know this because everything in
the universe is expanding the same way
so we only get to sense things where
there's a difference in the expansion
rate between one thing and another and
so the expansion of the universe that we
already know about the thing that
happened that started in the Big Bang
that expansion is an expansion of things
that are not otherwise being held
together so for example galaxies do not
expand galaxies are held together by the
force of gravity and they don't expand
but but a cluster of galaxies doesn't
expand much if you look at between
clusters of galaxies the distances
between clusters of galaxies do increase
and what really happens is that the the
expansion of the universe is like
another kind of force of gravity that's
pulling things apart and there's a small
force that does that and that force is
being balanced against forces that hold
things together so the force that holds
us together the intratomic forces that
hold a sort of standard solid material
object together are unbelievably much
stronger than the forces that are the
forces of expansion of the universe and
we only get to see the expansion of the
universe where I'm at a scale where even
gravity doesn't affect that so this
question about saying well can you take
a block of space and change its size
that's a very slippery question and and
really the only way that we get to make
boxes of space that we know of is in
black holes because the Event Horizon
defines this kind of the boundary of the
box now it's an interesting question I I
will say back in 1981 I wrote a couple
of papers with a friend of mine and Jan
ambion who um about it was called
properties of the vacuum and so we had
part one was called mechanical
properties of the vacuum we were
interested in vacuum fluctuations and uh
associated with you put the vacuum in a
metal box and you just sort of change
the size of the metal box what happens
how does it affect the the volume of
vacuum that's inside the metal box and
we figured out some kind of interesting
things then we started the part two was
an electrodynamic properties of that if
you put an electric field you can strain
it with an electric field what happens
then all kinds of other exotic phenomena
we had promised a part three in that
series of papers back in 1981 that was
going to be about the gravitational
effects of these things well we never
wrote it uh kind of and it turns out
um
with our model of physics
I think we're finally in a position to
write that paper and so I I might um if
I have the time
I've been telling um my former
collaborator yarn that um
we should do this for a number of years
and he doesn't believe me when I say
look I'm pretty efficient now at doing
science and things like that you know
maybe I will take a vacation weekend so
to speak and try and try and uh you know
churn this out he doesn't believe that
but um uh we'll see uh it's kind of a a
vacation on um studying the
gravitational properties of the vacuum
but I think I think now we're finally in
a position to do that and this notion of
what there's a box of vacuum look like
you know you can constrain a box of
vacuum with event Horizons can you
constrain it any other way can you
describe the size of a region of space
by some method other than that and maybe
you can maybe you can have something
where you have essentially test
particles and you're describing the size
of this region of space by asking where
the test particles go which is
essentially a statement of the structure
of the of the curvature of space-time
and the gravity and space time I'm not
sure I mean that's a it's a that's a
good question come on come on sort of
discuss the um uh the kind of the size
of boxes of space you know space
even in the standard theory of gravity
is a little bit like an elastic medium
it's a little bit like some some kind of
deformable material although it has
rather different strange characteristics
with respect to that and it's as I was
mentioning realistic relativistic
mattresses interesting points that we
don't know how to explain what a solid
like a thing held together by
enterotonic forces what that is like
relativistically the one kind of
material that we know how it works
relativistically is space-time and it
has its own constitutive relations as
they're called that relate kind of
stresses and strains and things like
this and and it has those things
although it's pretty exotic relative to
uh material objects and one of the big
questions actually in studying uh even
in traditional uh theories of gravity is
just what kinds of material can exist in
space-time so so two of the
characteristics are the pressure and the
energy density so the one of the things
that's always assumed is that the
pressure of anything is less than
one-third of its energy density where
energy density is measured in units with
speed of light square and all kinds of
other equals mc squared like stuff but
for a radiation gas like Photon gas P
the pressure is equal to one-third of
the energy density and it is believed
that you can't have any kind of material
stuff where the pressure is larger than
the um uh
one third of the energy density so in
other words there's no there's no way to
make that out of any kind of stuff in
the universe so it's an interesting
question which I don't know the answer
to whether in our models of physics it's
possible to get P greater than one third
row pressure greater than one third of
energy dense today that's an interesting
question it should that should be looked
at
all right
um I should wrap up here
thanks for um uh
all those um
all those comments
um oh I see
somebody pasted the result from wolfen
alpha for 100 billion I think we should
add a couple of um a couple of
comparisons there I think more unknown
um and and one was suggested here about
atoms in the bacterium
um all right well thanks thanks a lot to
everybody and um uh see you another time
and uh bye for now